also ich muss ehrlich sagen es
enttäuscht mich sehr dass ich 40 stunden
arbeiten gehe und eigentlich ja monats
an der weniger hat als wenn ich nicht
arbeiten gehen würde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin jessica bin alleinerziehende
mama die vollzeit arbeiten und trotzdem
muss ich mit hartz4 aufstocken
[Musik]
ich bin generation merke sie hat 16
jahre lang mein leben beeinflusst und
ich bin froh wenn ihre politik beendet
ist
[Musik]
ich habe mahler lackiererin gelernt
musste aus gesundheitlichen gründen um
schulen und bin jetzt industriekauffrau
arbeitet derzeit in einem stadttheater
einer buchhaltung
also ich gehe zu den berliner enge da
gehe ich jetzt ein bisschen was
einkaufen beim ihr obst gemüse oder auch
andere sachen einfach günstiger kommt
eine kaufhalle hole die berliner enge
sind schon vereinen die kriegen spenden
von kaufen und alles und da kann halt
hilfebedürftige wie hartz 4 empfänger
geringverdiener hat günstig die
lebensmittel dann wieder kaufen und ich
finde es eine echt gute unterstützung
zwischendurch auch kleidung oder andere
sachen
ich habe mal wieder eine verlängerung
ein neuer bescheid ist da
ich weiß ich wie ich immer bin habe ich
alles dabei
einmal der aktuelle bescheid bist du
jetzt bist du zum 21 da einkaufen gehen
zu können sollte man halt
geringverdiener seien oder in
irgendwelchen leistungsbezügen stehen
sie muss man nachweisen und schon kriegt
man ein kärtchen womit man dann auch
dort einkaufen gehen also ich gehe zwar
vollzeit jetzt arbeiten da ich aber nur
mindestlohn habe muss ich trotzdem noch
mit hartz iv aufstocken was halt den
vorteil für mich hat er sich noch so
eine vergünstigung nutzen darf würde ich
jetzt ein paar euro mehr verdienen
durfte ich nicht mehr bei dann würde ich
kein hartz 4 empfänger mehr sein dann
wäre es noch schlechter als jetzt
hätte ich meinen job perfekt
[Musik]
schicke sachen hab da wieder die doch
also pro woche haben wir knapp 200 euro
die wir für einkauf essen trinken was
auch immer noch benötigt wird verwenden
können durch corona hat sich unser
wochen budget geführt verkleinert weil
in den geschäften dass alles teurer
geworden aber es geht was ich zur
verfügung habe hat ist nicht mehr
dadurch dass ich das nutzen kann können
wir auf jeden fall gesund leben würde
ich jetzt nicht
die berliner engel nutzen können müsste
ich auf vieles an obst und gemüse
verzichten weil ich sage dass es halt
schweineteuer in der kaufhalle da ist
dosenfutter günstiger und ich versuche
doch solange es geht wenn er frisch zu
kochen für meine kinder
[Musik]
also die waren hier die sind kurz vorm
ablaufen oder sind halt schon ein tag
abgelaufen von diesem verfallsdatum her
aber man weiß ja wie sachen sie dann
trotzdem noch gut sie sind ja dass ich
mich schlecht aber eine kaufhalle kauft
keiner deswegen spende die geschäfte des
hat und ich freue mich darüber ich kann
meinen kindern auch markensachen wollen
und zeit nicht so viel wie der
kasseler ich bin fertig
[Musik]
euro zu bitte
hast dich ja hier etwa
dankeschön
kaffeetasse
ist doch logisch mensch wusste gar nicht
dass es so vieles was ich gekauft habe
[Musik]
na kaufhalle würde ich das niemals zu
günstig bekommen also und da ist mir das
dann auch relativ dass ich sage manches
ist jetzt abgelaufen oder soweit es ist
trotzdem gut und selbst wenn jetzt mal
ein joghurt nicht schmeckt dann
schmeißen wir den weg aber ich habe
trotzdem noch gespart klar wäre ich froh
wenn ich so viel verdienen können wir ja
ich kann mir das auch alles in der
kaufhalle leisten aber es ist leider
nicht so und somit bin ich froh dass es
die berliner engel gibt wo mir die
möglichkeit gegeben wird trotzdem meine
kinder auf dem gleichen level halten zu
können
wir sehen uns wir hören uns na klar und
ich danke dir nur enzler
[Musik]
kommst du mir helfen ja also derzeit
verdiene ich mindestlohn von 9 50 die
stunde brutto und tariflohn werden
eigentlich bei mir knapp 18 euro brutto
das heißt wirklich einen tariflohn
stelle haben könnten wir ohne hartz 4
und ich könnte sogar sagen ich kann ihn
auf die ermäßigung als verzichten und
wir stehen nicht schlechter da als mit
hartz 4 also ich würde sagen politisch
müsste man so viel ändern dass zum
beispiel die firmen weniger abgaben
haben damit die bessere gehälter zahlen
kann werden eine möglichkeit in meinen
augen du sagen mal wenn man schon bei
der schulsachen sind wie sieht denn
deine maus auch sehr gut bist du schon
fertig ja also fertig kannst du mir das
alles zeigt also thema homeschooling hat
schon mehr kosten verursacht also ich
muss den drucker besorgen ich musste
druckerpapier besorgen die hilfen wie
kleine zuschüsse und dergleichen die ich
als hartz4 empfänger beantragen konnte
sind erst am ende gekommen brauchst du
danach etwas von deinem sport an
zusammen sicher ich gehe nur noch mal um
einkaufen ja alles okay
dann bin ich ja beruhigt junger mann ich
denke schon dass ich mich ein bisschen
einschränken also die frau die ich
ständig neue klamotten kauft oder so bin
ich nicht weil ich sah das geld stecke
ich lieber an die kinder sei es für die
schule oder sei zeit für aktivitäten
dass sie auch so vom sozialen leben was
mitbekommen können und nicht nur durch
zu hause rumsitzen müssen
[Musik]
also ich finde jedes kind sollte ein
anrecht auf ein eigenes zimmer haben und
das habe ich meinen kindern auch
ermöglicht dafür habe ich auf ein
eigenes zimmer verzichtet weil wir auch
nur eine 4 raum wohnung zusteht und
schlafe dann halt lieber wohnzimmer aber
jedes meiner kinder den rückzugsraum hat
sein eigenes reich
bei großtanks war immer dass ich kinder
dann habe die sagen sie gehen ich
arbeite die bleiben lieber zu hause
sitzen weil für zu hause sitzen mal mehr
gekriegt als wenn man arbeitet also mir
war es auch mal richtig eigentlich den
kindern das zu zeigen dass man arbeiten
muss also ich hab eine ausbildung
gefunden
ich habe auch einen ausbildungsplatz
auch schon auch schon unterschrieben ich
freue mich auf die ausbildung weil dann
kann ich mein geld verdienen und ich
wollte auch nicht so tief ein wenn man
ganz unten ist wieder hochzukommen das
ist auch sehr schwierig weil dann hat
man so ein stempel sag ich mal auf der
stelle ich lebe von hartz 4 leben
leichter machen nichts kümmern sich
nicht um die kinder rauchen trinken
alkohol das finde ich nicht schön aber
meine mama ist ein gutes beispiel so
macht es halt nicht so
ich mache heute einen kurzausflug gärten
der welt in meinen jungs einfach mal ein
bisschen raus an die frische luft gucken
auf uns da auf wo gemütlich kurz hinter
zu können vielleicht ein paar pommes
essen oder so wenn die jungs denn noch
ein bisschen da bleiben wurden die
praktisch nur noch ein bisschen lernen
halt mal besonders gefragt nicht nur zu
hause
[Musik]
also ich bin froh dass ich noch hat viel
bescheid habe
würde ich die nicht haben hätte ich im
monat 4 bis 5 600 euro mehrausgaben weil
ich natürlich durch diesen
hartz-iv-bescheid noch vergünstigungen
habe das heißt ich brauche keine gez
bezahlen ich kriege die schulbücher für
meine kinder bezahlt ich kriege
zuschüsse für sportvereine
ich kann wenn sie auf eine gruppenfahrt
den krieg da auch nochmal zuschüsse muss
es nicht aus eigener tasche alles selber
bezahlen ich krieg rabatte bei den
mitgliedsbeiträgen
das macht sich schon bemerkbar ob ich
jetzt nun hat hier bescheid für 100 euro
habe oder ob ich 100 euro mehr im
portemonnaie haben das ist auch noch mal
so ein ding wo ich eigentlich gar nicht
hin also man muss eigentlich gucken dass
man selbst inmitten euro im harz 4
bleibt um den kindern mehr bieten zu
können als wenn man ein paar euro mehr
im portemonnaie oder auf dem neuen
streifen hat
also wir gehen den gärten der welt zum
schnitt alle 14 tage wenn das wetter
dementsprechend das ist sie ein fall
heute
wird ja vorne denn ab dann kann es war
alex nein also mir ist es sehr wichtig
dass meine kinder verschiedene
freizeitangebote haben und dass sie auch
ein bisschen was erleben und sehen
können das ist mir schon wichtig und ich
könnte das gehört auch mit zur
allgemeinbildung dass man nicht nur die
eigene stadt kennt sondern auch ein
bisschen über den tellerrand hinaus was
weiß
alles er alles ist ja auch weiter
glücklich ich glaube hier rum und fangen
meine pokémons das ist so meine freizeit
hobby und hier in gärten der welt können
wir alles unter die jungs am plätze zum
schönen die mädchen haben wir einen mega
den wasserspielplatz und
ich kann mit freunden dem hobby
nachgehen pokémon zu fangen
[Musik]
für mich ist es dieses unterwegssein hat
kopf abschalten ich meine klar wenn ich
noch ein paar freunde treffe ist es auch
schön sie ein bisschen abwechslung aber
so ist hauptsächlich dass ich so ein
bisschen kopf frei kriegen kann und dann
auch wieder mich auf die aufgaben zu
hause konzentrieren zu können
arbeiten lohnt sich für mich in dem
sinne für selbstwertgefühl auch für die
vorbildfunktion und finanziell lohnt
sich für mich muss arbeiten nicht also
ich würde mir von der neuen regierung
wünschen dass sie vorrangig guckt auf
ihr volk braucht was wollen die leute
hier die in deutschland leben arbeiten
also ich würde mir für meine kinder
wünschen dass sie ihren traumberuf
machen können und dass sie damit so viel
geld verdienen dass sie sich und ihre
familie auch damit ernähren können
später und dass er glücklich werden
noch mehr porträts findet ihr in der
mediathek
[Musik]